hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
at the very core of Martin heidegger's
essay plato's doctrine of truth is in
fact the discussion of two different
perspectives attitudes or you might say
comportment towards truth how do we
understand what truth is and Heidegger
takes Plato as doing something that is
determinative not only for Plato not
only for his immediate followers but
really for the entire history of Western
metaphysics and as he calls it and we're
gonna look at that history in a
different video but right now let's
concentrate on what he's saying about
Plato's own transformation that's taking
place here in the understanding of truth
in the allegory of the cave so we have
what Heidegger calls the original
essence of truth pre-socratic pre
Platonic and truth is a lethea and that
means unhidden as' or you know an
unforgiving is another way of
translating that
we'll come back to that in a moment but
what is he contrasting it against what
is the fundamental transformation that
that Plato is bringing about that we see
not only in the rest of Plato's
dialogues but particularly crystallized
here in the allegory of the cave there's
really two parts to it we could say that
instead of being understood as Alafaya
truth is now being understood as ortho
tastes rightness or correctness but
Heidegger I think rightly points out
that you don't have any correctness or
correspondence or rightness within Plato
without there also being the mediating
factor of the idea of the form that
which shows forth as he says that which
reveals itself and this is in fact a
kind of unhidden as' but it's an
unwritten 'us
range of beings taken as paradigmatic so
let's come back for a moment
to talk about the original essence of
truth as that which were moving away
from so Heidegger tells us several
important things along the way one is
that he says that truth as Alafaya is
what has been rested from from
hiddenness what has been drawn out of it
so in a way you know Plato himself in in
telling the allegory in doing dialectics
and doing everything that he's doing is
in fact relying on this earlier
conception this more primal way of
understanding truth but he's going to
transform it what else can we say
Heidegger tells us that Allie Thea
remains unhidden as' in relation to what
remains hidden so that you can never
reveal everything there's always going
to be this play of what is hidden in
relation to what is unhidden what is
unhidden can show forth you might say
against the background or by contrast to
what remains hidden and so the ancient
Greeks in Heidegger's view didn't
attempt until the time of Plato or
perhaps even you know Socrates before
him to try to make everything manifest
to try to bring everything into presence
for the the human being to make
everything intelligible the other thing
that he says that's really fundamentally
important here is that truth understood
as Alethea is a fundamental trait of
beings themselves so that every single
thing has its own truth to it it's truth
is not as it will be with Plato
dependent upon it being related to the
idea it has its truth it has its
capacity for revealing itself to us for
uncovering itself for coming out of
hiddenness on its own account and human
beings are the witnesses of this
rather than you might say the measure of
it or you might say human beings draw
some of these things out but they don't
draw it out necessarily according to a
method now what happens with this
platonic conception as I mentioned he's
going to talk about the idea and ortho
tastes or correctness so the first thing
that he he tells us is that this is
talking about the allegory of the cave
and he says that certainly unhidden is's
mentioned in its various stages but it's
considered simply in how it makes
whatever appears be accessible in its
visible form it's a dose a dose an idea
are very closely connected right both of
them are used almost synonymously by by
Plato the visible form and in terms of
how it makes this visible form as that
which shows itself which is what
Heidegger takes idea to be to be telling
how it makes it be visible and remember
to in the allegory of the cave the
visibility is not primarily that of the
material objects but that of the forms
that those material objects are copies
of so he says this reflection focuses on
the visible forms appearing the visible
form provides a view of that as which
any given being is present the
reflection proper aims at the idea so
when we're looking at say sheet of paper
we are looking at this physical object
but we are we are going beyond it in our
mind in our mind's eye as we use the
locution the metaphor about that and we
are thinking about something like an
ideal form of paper or perhaps
rectangularity or whatever it else it is
that we're connecting it up with it
gives it intelligibility so he says the
idea is a visible form that offers a
view of what is present and here's a
really important thing the idea does not
first let something else behind it shine
and appear it is itself what shines this
is you know again in the allegory but
also in plato's other doctrine the idea
of the form
the intelligible is what is most true
what is most understandable what what
reveals itself the most what actually
has the most being to in platonic
metaphysics
and neo platonic metaphysics so he's
going to go on and he he makes a
historical observation here he says this
is why for Plato the proper essence of
being consists in its what nests
what is that kind of thing what is this
sheet of paper what is this article of
clothing here what is this person that
you're seeing is it the existense eeeh
the existence the the being that that
places itself forward by the way the in
latin existense eeeh doesn't just mean
bare existence until really about
halfway through the the the Middle Ages
you can see this very clearly in authors
like for example Anselm of Canterbury
where existense iya still has the sense
of something that stands forth that that
comes out right a little bit of a
digression there coming back he says for
Plato the proper essence of being
consistent what Ness even later
terminology shows us quit eat us not
existense iya quit eat us is the oneness
right quit what the thing is existential
its existence quit eat us is the true
essay that is its essentia it what what
the essence of the thing is from a
platonic perspective the form of human
being is more real than me the form of
tai is more real than this particular
tai the form of sheet of paper the idea
of it is more real is more intelligible
it is what allows us to recognize this
material object as sheet of paper this
thing as tie this person as human being
so he says this the unhidden right
or he says what the idea in a shining
forth brings into view and thereby lets
us see for the gaze focused on the idea
the unhidden of that as which the idea
appears the unhidden is grasped
antecedently getting hidden is grasped
antecedent laid before and by itself as
that which is apprehended in
apprehending the idea is that which is
known in the act of knowing so he calls
this a platonic revolution and he says
that this is going to lead us to a
different conception of reason a little
bit later on he's going to continue
these remarks and deepen them he says
that we have a transformation of the
essence of truth taking place in the
allegory of the cave and in plato's work
in general it's also a change he says of
the locus of truth whereas in the
earlier conception of truth which
Heidegger thinks is still accessible and
available to us because it is the
original primal essence of truth
everything possesses its truth
everything can shine forth everything
can be a locus of revealing or unhiding
you might say for Plato that's not the
case anymore
the idea is the locus of truth or rather
that which places itself in relation to
the idea so unhidden this now becomes as
we say dependent upon the idea truth
becomes correctness ortho tastes being
right correctness of what correctness of
apprehending that is something cognitive
right or perceptual and of he says
asserting so we see truth becomes
something that is essentially a property
no longer of being as such although it's
not really a property but rather
something of thoughts and language this
is what Heidegger takes to be a
fundamental revolution a transformation
in the concept
of truth so he says with this the with
this transformation of the essence of
truth
there takes place at the same time a
change the locus of truth as unhidden as
truth is still a fundamental trait of
beings themselves but as the correctness
of the gaze of that which the human
being that which is looking upon the
ideas it becomes a characteristic of
human comportment towards being a little
bit later he's going to talk about
humanism and its relation to this so
what is actually happening here he a
little bit earlier than that he says
that everything depends on the ortho
taste the correctness of the gaze
through this correctness seeing or
knowing become something correct so that
in the end it looks directly at the
highest idea and fixes itself in this
direct alignment it gets its gaze better
and better more correct he says in so
directing itself apprehending conforms
itself to what is to be seen the visible
form the the idea the a dose what
results from this he says is a home
oasis that is a conformity a agreement
you might say so this is a very
important transformation and a little
bit later on he says the intellects
judgment and assertion becomes the place
of truth and he tells us that here's
here's what we'll end with these
reflections truth is no longer as it was
qua hiddenness the fundamental trait of
being itself instead as a consequence of
being yoked he says under the idea truth
becomes correctness and henceforth it
will become a characteristic of the
knowing of beings one particular being
is doing that knowing human being and
truth now falls within the province no
longer of being and beings as such but
of a particular class of being and our
relation to that so the human gaze right
becomes
central we have an agreement between the
human gaze and the idea what happens to
truth and things it becomes if not
entirely unconceivable secondary
auxilary he even talks at a certain
point about truth being understood as
Earth rotates or correctness giving us
what the the idea is and then there's
still the realm of beauty that has to do
with unhidden as' but what is Plato
primarily interested in according to
Heidegger it's this correctness this
relationship to the ideas so this really
is a fundamental transformation in the
entire notion of what truth is a
departure from a earlier and in some
ways more perennial conception of truth
you